rise manor area golf course has closed
and could soon be turned into a housing
development according to the royal links
golf club's website the club stopped
operating last month the location is on
vegas valley drive just east of nellis
that's where we find joe moeller joining
us live with who owns the property now
and the plans moving forward
bryant county records show that
touchstone living is now the owner of
the property here this now closed golf
club the developer has a few
neighborhoods being built around the
valley those catering to first time home
buyers
just the view
that's what sold me on the house jeannie
and patrick emerson can see the royal
links golf club from their yard it's
concerning because we're going to be
losing a few they are sad to see it
close it's very nice and quiet right now
it's not going to it's not going to be
like that plus the traffic the course
closed in december and dirt is moving
according to county records touchstone
living purchased it and planned to build
more than a thousand homes there are a
number of touchstone living properties
around the valley the neighborhoods are
known to be affordable development in
that area has not been something that
has historically been happening as
development booms in other areas real
estate agent john fallas says this could
be good for the economic growth in the
sunrise manor area he says it could
provide more options for first-time
homebuyers in a tough market properties
that i have listed in our brokerage it's
not uncommon to see upwards of 20 plus
offers within the first week of
when a home hits the market underneath
400 000 due to a number of factors
limited inventory across the board
obviously but less than 600 homes for
sale underneath 400 000 in the entire
valley right now people living in this
area do have concerns about what exactly
it will look like over their fence the
slice of heaven right here bill trobeck
enjoyed the view from his deck he has
questions about what exactly he'll be
looking at in the future i know it was
going to happen he wasn't happy about it
but he can't stop him
i did try to get a hold of touchstone
living for comment they are not talking
about this project at this time we did
not get any answers regarding details we
were trying to get today but it is
unclear right now what exactly building
will start here but we did see some
construction crews out here today
reporting live joe mohler live local now